you know I'm really glad that this thing
is taking its musical vibe from hip-hop
because otherwise you know that first
episode would have been blasting back in
black black lightning I actually had
meant to to cover the premiere episode
back when it first aired but I got
wrapped up in a whole bunch of other
stuff and I completely missed that it it
happened but I've now seen the first two
episodes and I kinda want to talk first
impressions depending on the interest
level I may or may not do more reviews
episode by episode as it goes on there's
only 13 in this first season I'm still
debating that I'm probably still gonna
watch the show though which is that's
your spoiler free version of my thoughts
which is yeah this is pretty good I'm
actually quite enjoying it I won't talk
too much in the way of spoilers then
again its first two episodes it's
primarily set up there isn't really that
much to spoil but you know just consider
that a warning I'll try and not get into
them there might be a few but it's not a
spoiler kind of show not in the first
two episodes anyways
so Black Lightning he's basically a
retired superhero he used to defend this
town and then you know take care of the
citizens and he Eenie was taking on like
a major sort of local crime gang leader
you know the overlord of things but he
retired and he retired primarily because
of his wife and his family his two
daughters but now it's some time later
he has made a career for himself as the
principal of the local high school where
he actually keeps things pretty under
control he treats everybody in his
school pretty much pretty well which
means that when there were people who
were under him who graduated and
inevitably some of them got involved in
the local gang called the 100 they had
enough respect for him that they obeyed
his desire to keep their involvement at
the school itself down to a minimum to
basically not have them there at all I
mean they're snatching these you know
participants elsewhere but you get the
sense that he is really a pillar of this
community and so he's been still trying
to fight the good fight in a non
superhero kind of
way rather than what he had been doing
as the vigilante black lightning in the
past but as you would expect he gets
called back into action and I like the
way that that builds up well all the
most of the things about this setup I
really like let me just actually start
with the lead though Chris Williams is
an actor I am not particularly familiar
with I have seen some of the things he's
been in but I checked his IMDB page I'm
like I've seen that I don't remember him
in it that's not to say he wasn't
memorable it really looks like he was
stuck in a lot of minor roles at least
in the things that I saw him in he's
really good here he has a great presence
he has a wonderful set in and he has
because he has to basically do two
things he has to be that uplifting
charismatic character when he is
fulfilling his life as the principal to
make you believe that people even gang
leaders respect him so much that they
want to do right by him and yet at the
same time he also has to be legitimately
intimidating not just you know
physically because he's a big guy but
also just in terms of being able to
exude a sense of strength and power that
would render people going oh okay this
is a problem I gotta leave and he's able
to do both of those and he does both of
them not just well but excellently they
have him blatantly laid out exactly what
his powers are and how they're worth
they're obviously lightening bass he can
hurl lightning around and he can
actually if he's connected by a
lightning bolt so somebody can pick
people up and move them that way I don't
think he himself is bulletproof I think
that's his armor but he's he's got it
he's got a powers up it's easy enough to
wrap your head around even though I
don't know all the ins and outs of it
one little touch that I really like when
he starts getting worked up his eyes
sort of flash this sort of white
electric right around the iris and you
know what it reminds me of the old
Incredible Hulk show when Bill Bixby's
eyes would go green right before he
transformed into the Hulk it gives me
that vibe and that's a good thing to
pull from when you when you have someone
who you know kind of manifests these
otherworldly powers that they're
otherwise trying to keep a lid on pretty
much all the performances are good if
I'm honest I do think kress Williams is
the big stand up but they're all good
the two the two young women who play his
daughters are very good the woman who
plays his wife is good they've got very
good chemistry which is which is really
nice I'm a little bit iffy on their sort
of relationship they name it cuz it's
currently working I I might come back to
that a little bit later
it's got James remar in it as sort of
his friend who texts him out and makes
his gear I love James remar I've loved
James remar since I first noticed him
playing Dexter's dad so yeah I I'm
always happy to see him he has this very
easygoing sense of authority to him it's
hard to nail down but he brings that
here as he pretty much always does I was
impressed by the villains actually
because quite no first first two
episodes in we met sort of the big head
honcho that's gonna be at the very least
a season-long issue to be dealt with but
we've been dealing mostly with gang
members that haven't stuck around too
long you know they're basically only
here for an episode or two before they
get taken out of the story one way or
the other but they're still surprisingly
working there's a there's an and there's
an element to this that I can't describe
as anything other than honesty they're
they they feel a lot more real than most
gang members I've seen depicted in
television and in movies now I you know
understand consider the source I have no
basis on which to judge what is or isn't
real in terms of how gangs actually work
zip I've got no standing on that but
what I can tell you is that often times
when a violent gang particularly a black
gang is depicted in a lot of TV shows
and movies they feel very overblown they
feel like caricatures these characters
don't feel like caricatures even the
minor ones that we get they feels like
there is some depth there they've
obviously been gone in a very bad
direction but they don't feel like like
straw men they feel like actual people
and you get little glimpses of oh okay
maybe there was at some point something
I saw or maybe they're even still is but
it's it's overwritten by this other
stuff that they're doing and it's hard
for me to nail that exact
why that comes across but it does and
it's a sense I've gotten from from the
various gang member so far not so much
from the head guy cuz I mean his job is
to just be you know the big intimidating
guy which he does pretty well he's he's
the only one so far who's kind of
bordering on generic but it's working so
far because again they got an actor with
a very good physical presence that
certainly helps and he hasn't been
called upon yet to do much more than
just be there and occasionally do things
to to remind the audience is why he's a
bad guy pretty much just hanging around
with a giant neon sign over his head
that says I'm gonna be a boss fight so
you know the he's working fine but the
ones under him yeah there's a weird
layer of death I don't want to oversell
it they're not like deep well explored
characters they're there for short
periods of time but they just feel more
fleshed out in a way and I think in a
lot of ways that kind of exemplifies
this show as a whole at least these
first two episodes there's pretty much
nothing going on here that is
particularly surprising or anything that
I haven't seen done elsewhere it's just
being executed very well all the pieces
really work because then this is
something where if any of these elements
or certainly if multiple of them were
just okay as opposed to good then the
whole thing would just read generic
mediocre because on paper it kind of is
it goes exactly where you think it's
going the the by and large the
characters do what you expect these
characters to do but it's just got a
polished to it the piece is being used
to tell this not exactly you know
groundbreaking story are all really
refined pieces all of its just really
working very well and sometimes you
don't need a story to reinvent the wheel
and bring you know or do something that
you've never thought of before sometimes
it's nice just to get something that is
familiar but just really well delivered
and that's the vibe I get off black
lightning so far I am having a lot of
fun with it it's really enjoyable
there's a good sense of weight and drama
to the moments that are supposed to have
that it is fun and energetic and
cathartic when it when it needs to be
the action scene
are not amazing but for a TV budget are
pretty darn good
as far as nitpicks go the I don't love
his outfit there's something about the
sort of lit up lightnings across
lightning bolts across the chest that
reads more cosplay than anything else so
I'm not in love with it it's not
terrible though and what I do like is
when he's out in that outfit I love the
way people react to him I love that he
goes to this hotel where he knows all
you know the specific gang member that
he's after as well as this whole group
of other gang members are gonna be there
he goes up the doorman season goes black
left and my man just opens the door and
tells him what floor the guy he's
looking for is that and the maintenance
worker in the elevator holds the
elevator offers to give backlight being
lift up I love that and there that's
another thing that's really nice that
that this has is that it has a sense of
history because this is Black Lightning
coming back we're not getting an org
origin story we're getting a back in the
saddle story which we don't have quite
as many of in terms of these kinds of
shows and superhero stories that we're
getting you know in medium aside from
comic books we mostly get origin stories
but this is not an origin story this is
a this is a coming out of retirement
story and that's not massively different
but it's different enough to help it not
feel as stale as it very easily could've
the other thing that I kind of alluded
to initially the relationship between
Black Lightning and his what ball
ex-wife there's nothing wrong with it
and like I said they have good chemistry
is maybe I was miss reading it but there
was a read I got on the relationship
initially that the interpretation that I
had of it I liked better than what they
actually did cuz the real I got on and
initially was he very very clearly
wanted them to be together again and she
very clearly still cared about him but
the read I had on it was that she cared
about him and always would but also knew
that they were never gonna be together
and it wasn't gonna work and she didn't
want to actually go back to him again as
much as you know she may have loved him
even now and there so the read I had on
it
that he was really he really had sort of
rose-colored glasses on looking at
basically a lack of rejection and taking
it as things are gonna be better she's
gonna come back and be fixed and that
was my read on it and again maybe I
misread it because by the second episode
is pretty clear that she actually is
ready to go that direction and then
we're gonna be getting probably a much
more I guess expected and typical she
wishes he wouldn't go out as Black
Lightning but he still feels the need to
do that kind of thing which that's a
dynamic that I've seen a bit more before
and the dynamic that I apparently
invented in my head I liked better
because it didn't seem as well-worn a
territory sort of coming back to
something else I like I love that there
are multiple layers to his getting back
in the saddle and doing this and taking
up the vigilante mantle again because
initially it is to protect his own
family his family his daughters are in
danger he puts on the suit goes and does
it but the show then does a really good
job of hammering home the guilt he's
gonna feel out the fact that he did that
for his kids but so many other people's
kids kids that he knows are in danger
and he's not doing anything for them and
it's managing to really convey the
weight of that on on him as a character
and that comes across really well and is
a really good way to motivate him and
and keep him going into and to make us
as audience members want him to do this
because if it was a completely
self-serving motivation it was only
about protecting his family I'm not
gonna say that couldn't work but you
know then it really massively depends on
depends on you have to care about these
specific characters a lot whereas if you
expand it out and you make you make it
so you want him to save this community
which it got me there within two
episodes then it really makes you pull
for him to put on that suit again so
when he does
makes it all the more cathartic and
triumphant and I'm I am really enjoying
this again I I don't want to oversell it
it's it's not like at this whole new
level something we've never seen before
like I said it is pretty much as you
would expect but it's done with
characters and a setting that I have not
seen used as much before I don't know
how much people are comparing this to
Luke Cage I'm sure it's in there a
little bit I think there's a certain
similar vibe that you they use similar
music cues but the the feel of the
character certainly is very different
from Luke Cage at least as he was in the
one season of his show that we've gotten
so far I would say a more apt comparison
point of comparison would be the
organized crime and the gangs that each
are coming are coming up against because
whereas in the first season of Luke Cage
they did a really great job building up
an initial villa and only to get rid of
him halfway through the show and bring
in a guy I'd never seen and it only
heard of by name and knew nothing about
and that just didn't work whereas Black
Lightning so far we've been dealing with
lower-level guys but we know the threat
we know who the big guy hovering over
that is and yet the lower-level guys
don't just feel like fodder they do feel
like a genuine problem in and of
themselves so I think it's if nothing
else is valiant seeing its villains
better than Luke Cage did but it's also
doing some different things it really is
going at this from the angle of black
lightning and and also you know the this
guy when he is the principal as well
being a pillar of the community he's not
just coming in to cleaning up and to
clean up the streets he's coming in to
lift up the people around him and that's
that's good stuff oh and the one thing
that is a bit spoiler ish so if you've
been sticking through and you you do
want to avoid spoilers I'd bow out right
now okay the thing with the older
daughter starting to exhibit powers I'm
curious how that's gonna go because I
find her intriguing as a character
especially knowing that she's motivated
by a lot of the same sort of social
causes that drove her father and still
drive him but he's now going about them
in a different way where she's much more
gung-ho you know take up the picket sign
and protest kind of person so I will be
interested to see how that plays out and
I think it could potential
be really intriguing could also be a
point where it goes off the rails but
you know who knows we'll see so Black
Lightning first two episodes have you
seen them what did you think about them
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it do all that stuff you know
the stuff the likes and subscribes and
listen to my podcast and follow me on
Twitter and maybe check out the patreon
thinking about dropping something just
in the tip jar
you know the options there links for all
that stuff is down below and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]